وكنا نتحدث عن لاعبين في
مصر لمغادرة مصر وأن الكثير من
اللاعبين المصريين لا يغادرون مصر ، فهي
تبقى في منطقة راحتهم بشكل
أساسي وأنا دائمًا شخص ما
يبحث دائمًا عن الحلول خارج غرفة الاجتماعات هذه ،
إنه رجل.  الذي
يبحث دائمًا عن الخطوة التالية دائمًا ما يبحث
عن مزيد من الكمال قليلاً وقد
طلب ذلك من اللاعبين من
حوله وهذا ما أحبه لدينا
جميع اللاعبين من جيلنا جميعهم
هم أمثلة هم ليسوا
نماذج للـ  جيل الشباب
وأكثر ليس مجرد مثال داخل
المبنى كل يوم في صالة الألعاب الرياضية على
أرض الملعب ، ينظر اللاعبون إليه ، فهم يرون
كيف يغري حذائه ويرون كيف
يضعون أكياس الساق ، ترى كيف
لمس الكرة التي يرونها عندما  إنه يمسك بالكرة
لذا ينظرون إليه ولا
أعتقد أنه لا توجد
صورة أكثر قوة كنموذج كمثال لذلك نحن
سعداء حقًا أنه معنا
لأنه هو الذي يقود فريقنا لدينا
كابتن ذكي  Henderson مع James Milner
بكلمات Mandyke ولكن أعتقد أن
أكثر من هو واحد من
القباطنة الذين لا يرتدون ألما وهو
اللاعب الوحيد الذي يتطلع إليه اللاعبون عندما يكون
حجم اللحظة التي يتعين فيها تنفيذ
العقوبة عندما تصبح المباراة.  قاسي وهو
يراوغ للرجل ويضع الكرة
فوق حارس المرمى
ويسدد لي أول طائرة إنه أه بالنسبة
لنا إنها فرحة وامتياز